"Eternals" is expanding the Marvel Cinematic
Universe like few movies have before it,
with a huge cast of characters, a grand scope,
and backstory that spans thousands of years.
It's also full of Easter eggs and references
to other movies in the MCU and beyond.
In playing Sersi, Gemma Chan joins the once rare,
now-growing “Two-Timers Club” of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
In case you don’t recall, Chan played the
Kree sniper Minn-Erva in 2019’s “Captain
Marvel,” although you could be
forgiven for not realizing it,
with the “Crazy Rich Asians” actor being basically
unrecognizable under layers of blue makeup.
She's one of the few actors who played
different characters within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe. But when you include other
movies based on Marvel Comics, from Fox, Sony,
or Marvel Studios' non-MCU Marvel Knights brand,
many actors have suited up for double duty.
That includes Chris Evans, who played Johnny
Storm in Fox's "Fantastic Four" movies before
suiting up as Steve Rogers; Josh Brolin,
who played Cable in Fox's “Deadpool 2" in
addition to the MCU's Thanos; Idris Elba,
who appeared as in Moreau in “Ghost Rider:
Spirit of Vengeance” the same year he began
playing Heimdall in the “Thor” movies;
Michael B. Jordan, who also played Johnny Storm
before he became Killmonger, and even more.
This group will soon be joined by Aaron
Taylor-Johnson, slated to play "Kraven the
Hunter" for Sony, previously seen as Quicksilver
in “Avengers: Age of Ultron,” and Mahershala Ali,
soon-to-star in “Blade,” after
previously being seen in “Luke Cage."
"Eternals” is said to take place
roughly eight months after “Avengers:
Endgame,” around the same time as the
events of “Spider-Man: Far From Home.”
When Ajak meets with Ikaris, she
mentions the seismic events of “Avengers:
Infinity War” and "Endgame." According to
her, the disruptive erasure and return of
so many people in the universe provided
the energy necessary to kickstart the
emergence -- the world-destroying threat
at the center of "Eternals'" plot.
“Thanos erased half of the population of
the universe. But the people of this planet
brought everyone back with the snap of a finger."
Later, Dane Whitman brings up
a big relevant question about
the Eternals' involvement -- or
lack thereof -- in those events.
“Why didn’t you guys help fight Thanos? Or any
war, or all the other terrible
things throughout history?”
Sersi justifies the Eternals' absence by saying
that humanity would have never had a chance to
develop if the super-beings had spent thousands
of years intervening in every crisis -- which
makes sense, even though it's not a good look
-- even Pepper Potts suited up to fight Thanos.
Among other references to
recent events in the MCU,
there's a news broadcast about
the movie's suspicious earthquake,
and someone can be heard speculating that it
might have something to do with “The Blip.”
Though it's happened plenty
of times in comics, so far,
the Marvel and DC universes
have yet to collide on screen.
That lends some significance to a couple
of conspicuous lines in “Eternals.”
The first comes when most of the Eternals get
together for a feast in modern-day Australia,
with some of the group catching up for the
first time in centuries. When Gilgamesh meets
Kingo's documentarian friend, he asks if he
serves the same function as Alfred in Batman.
"Don't wait up, Al!"
"I'll cancel the pizza!"
The second instance comes later in the
film, as Ikaris visits Chicago and the human
family of Phastos. When Ikaris meets the son of
Phastos, the boy remarks that he has seen him in
TV reports about the Deviants attacks, and that
he recognizes him as a very specific superhero.
"Dad! That's Superman! With the cape! And you
were shooting laser beams out of your eyes!"
"I don't wear a cape."
Now more than ever, it seems safe to say that
most characters in the MCU know who Superman,
Batman, Wonder Woman, Green
Lantern and the rest are — if
only because they’ve seen many of the
same movies and TV shows that we have.
"What's your superpower?"
The MCU has been going strong since 2008,
but Marvel Studios is still trying to rile
up today's teens with timely references
as the years go on. Fortnite, anyone?
"Thor, he's back. That kid on the
TV just called me a dickhead again."
The most obvious example of this in
"Eternals" is the movie's post-credits scene,
which brings Harry Styles to the MCU.
But another mega-popular musical act
also gets a shout out in this movie --
the worldwide phenomenon known as BTS.
When we first catch up with modern-day
Kingo, he seems to be having a blast.
The Eternal is a Bollywood star who
has convinced the world that his father
(secretly him) and grandfather (also
secretly him) were Bollywood actors
from generations past. Because he never
looks any older, Kingo has been starring
in Bollywood movies for decades with names
like “Shadow Warrior 2: Voyage of Time.”
As he explains his career in show business to
his so-called “friends from college,” Kingo
makes reference to BTS. Within moments, we cut to
the next scene — scored by the BTS song “Friends.”
"Eternals assemble."
As “Eternals” builds to its conclusion,
the reunited group pulls out all the stops in
an attempt to stop the emergence of Tiamatk.
Phastos speculates that if all the Eternals
were to combine their powers, it could be enough
to create something he dubs “the Uni-mind,”
allowing them to stop the end of the world.
If you’re familiar with the Eternals in the
comics, you know this is no mere speculation.
The Eternals have indeed employed the Uni-Mind
on multiple occasions, which has sometimes
manifested itself on the comic book page as a
gender-less being of light, mind and pure energy.
Typically, only the Prime Eternal can summon the
Uni-Mind, which is why in the film you see Gemma
Chan’s Sersi taking the lead. The Uni-Mind
never seems to take the form of a being,
yet it is clear that remaining Eternals have come
together to support the hypothesis of Phastos,
linking their minds and becoming more powerful
as a team than they ever could be apart.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.